- Yes when you met Meryl,
- I embarrassed myself.
- No you did not because--
- She's so scared of me.
- No she's not, she's not.
- Look at how intense my eyes are.
- No, well, okay.
- It's like I want to
wear her skin, I don't.
- No, your eyes were very
intense, 'cause I, (laughs)
- I didn't expect it to happen, y'all,
I'm not around actors ever, until now,
this show, but like I'm never,
I'm usually around musicians.
- It's was, actually a thing of beauty,
because I was walking this way
and I didn't realize that Meryl
was over here, how I don't even know,
but you were here and
your eyes were saucers.
And I was like--
- I was so excited.
- Oh my God, it's Kelly, and for a minute
I thought you were like,
eyes were saucers for me,
I was like how does she know it's me?
And then,
(laughter)
(applause)
- I'm so sorry!
- No, no, no!
- I freaked out!
- And then I walk and I'm
like, it's Kelly Clarkson!
And you turned to me and you
were like I just met Meryl.
And I was like--
- Oh my God, I blacked out.
I don't even remember that, I blacked out.
- And then I proceeded to
black out, we both blacked out.
- I blacked out, I was like,
I mean poor other girls,
they were just standing there
and I was like, and Meryl, hi.
- I would have done the same thing.
- I actually have met her
and blacked out as well.
- See?
- She has that--
- When I met her she actually
told me I was annoying
'cause she saw a play that I was in
and she meant it as a compliment
but the first words ever
from Meryl Streep were,
"Oh my God, you were so annoying."
(laughter)
- Are you dying?
'cause I'm dying for him.
I'm like so hurt.
- Oh my God.
- She meant it as like, good job.
- Of course she did but is that
what you want Meryl to say?
- The only thing I hear.
- Here's what I would
have taken from that,
she saw me in a play,
that's what I would have taken from that.
- Yes, after a few months of
therapy, that's what I thought.
- That is amazing.